كما تعلمون، أعتقد أن الكثير من الناس
يتساءلون كيف حدث هذا في العالم مع
العلم بالاستخبارات الإسرائيلية المتطورة
وهناك أيضًا مقطع فيديو
للسياج الحدودي الذي تم تدميره
أولاً، هل توافق على أن هذا كان
فشلًا استخباراتيًا كبيرًا وإذا كان
بإمكانك شرح كيف  لقد تكشف كل هذا،
لذا مرة أخرى من
وجهة نظر جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي، نحن لا نركز على ذلك
الآن، وأنا متأكد من أنه سيتم الحديث عن هذا
كثيرًا بمجرد انتهاء هذا الأمر، فنحن نقاتل الآن
هنا بشكل رئيسي حول غزة من أجل
حياة المدنيين لدينا.  سأتحدث
عما حدث بعد ذلك بحكمة استخباراتية
وأعني حماس التي كانوا
يهددونها لسنوات أعني في بعض الأحيان كان هناك
أشخاص يقولون لا إنه
مجرد كلام رأينا نية حماس
هناك إرهابي يريد
إبادة إسرائيل وأه  لقد
أظهروا نواياهم هذا الصباح من خلال
الغزو الكامل لإسرائيل من خلال
الصواريخ مع وصول الناس على
الشاحنات الأرضية، وهو أمر صعب للغاية بالنسبة
لجيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي، ونحن نقاتل الآن لاستعادة
السيطرة على المستوطنات المحيطة بقطاع
غزة على أبعد تقدير.  الرقم الذي
لدينا أه من جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي بشأن الصواريخ التي يتم
إطلاقها من غزة على إسرائيل هو 2000،
وهذا منذ بضع ساعات الآن، هل لديك
رقم محدث
لنا، لذا فمن المحتمل أنه تجاوز
خط 3000 مرة أخرى، كان هناك طلقة ضخمة هذا
الصباح  ما زال يطلق النار، أفترض أن
الأعداد حوالي 3000
ولكني لست متأكدًا بنسبة 100٪ ماذا عن
المدنيين هناك على الأرض الذين
يتعرضون للهجوم، لدينا تقارير عن
إطلاق النار على المدنيين، لدينا مقاطع فيديو
لسيارة يتم إطلاق النار عليها، كما نعلم  أنه
تم الاستيلاء على دبابة على الأقل من
مقاطع الفيديو التي رأيناها على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي،
ما الذي يتم القيام به لتأمين هؤلاء
السكان، هؤلاء المدنيين الذين هم تحت
الحصار الآن في جنوب
إسرائيل، لذا فقد أعلنا الآن أولاً وقبل كل
شيء  تجنيد
احتياطياتنا، نحن قوات متنقلة نزولاً
إلى الجنوب الآن لدينا
قوات خاصة تذهب إلى كل واحد من هذه
المواقع حيث يوجد قتال،
وهناك بينما نتحدث هناك معارك بالأسلحة النارية
للسيطرة على المنطقة وتنظيفها حيث
لدينا إرهابيون  جاء
وفعل ما فعلوه ورأيت
الصور التي قدمتها هداس تحديثًا جيدًا للغاية،
هل كان هناك رفض، نحن الآن
نمضي قدمًا، أيها
العقيد ما أقوله هو أننا الآن في
النهاية، هذا واحد  فرقة غزة، لقد
وضعنا الآن
فرقة أخرى أرسلناها وأرسلنا المزيد من
القوات والمزيد من القادة ونحن نتخذ
أولًا مرحلتنا الأولى وهي
إعادة الأمن إلى
المجتمعات هناك ومرة ​​أخرى
صباح صعب للغاية، الصور وأنت
ترى الصور، هل لديك
تقدير لعدد جنود الاحتياط الذين تم
استدعاؤهم بآلاف الآلاف وعشرات
الآلاف